bruno mingeon c'est l'homme qui glisse
dans sa tête pour préparer avec une
extrême concentration chaque descente en
bobsleigh cet équilibriste sur glace se
refait mentalement la descente pour
essayer de corriger ces défauts
améliorer sans cesse et trajectoire pour
aller toujours plus vite
beau dommage on est le meilleur club
français un talent naturel qu'il a
hérité de son père et de son grand-père
et c'est à l'aide de ses deux poignets
qu'il va tenter de diriger au mieux ce
tgv des glaces sur la piste olympique
des jeux de turin il ya beaucoup
d'anticipation puisque bon dès qu'on
rentre dans ce qu on sait déjà ce qu'on
va faire et on a déjà de façon à la
sortie de ce virage au niveau des mains
quand on a bien sûr des poignets
relayeur ou direction en ressent si on
fait trop si on fait passer si le dock
sud de pression si on commence à déraper
donc c'est vrai qu'on ressent aussi par
son corps parce par ses fesses aussi un
petit peu puisque l'on ressent le blog
d'un petit peu dérapé dans mon piste
dans cette équipe de france le rôle du
cruiser est également déterminant même
si la préparation du matériel est tout
aussi importante
le pousseur et recrutés au sein de
l'athlétisme français pierre à la
mèneront vient du décathlon et il a
trouvé là l'occasion de prolonger sa
carrière pour une bonne conversion entre
les jambes et les bras pour d'une part
arraché deux vols au départ et ensuite
rentré dans le bob et puis pas parcequ
ils vont dans tous les sens pas tomber
puisque son âge est forcément ça s'émeut
qu'il faut avoir le coeur bien accroché
pour descendre ce boulet givré à plus de
130 kilomètres/heure renommage médaillé
de bronze à nagano tentera avec son
équipage d'aller chercher un podium à
turin
même si ce début de saison n'a pas été
tout à fait satisfaisant pour l'équipe
de france
quand on vise une place dans les six
avec au jeu avec l'expérience de bruno
qui a déjà une médaille qui donc aura
forcément un peu moins de stress que les
autres eh ben on peut on peut encore pas
rêver puisque si c'était du domaine du
rêve ça voudra dire que c'est réalisable
mais on peut on peut faire de très
grandes choses sur la piste de turin
renommage ans qui participera à ses
cinquièmes et derniers jours à l' envie
de bien faire avant de passer les
commandes à la relève il déjà prêt enfin
presque